hello welcome to another video on code
Tech and tutorials today I'm I'm gonna
teach you a little bit about making
videos with blender a lot of people seem
to want to do this it's a good pretty
good free editor but it has its
limitations I want to go over those and
the example I'm going to give is from a
video I made on my gaming channel where
I did quite a bit of editing I'm going
to show you just walk through the video
and show you the techniques and what I
had to do to get it all lined up and I'm
gonna show you you know all that um I
was playing I was playing some pub G and
choco taco ended up absolutely
destroying my team and made a little
video out of it link below you're gonna
see my gaming channel doing that it's a
relatively unknown channel so subscribe
if you want to see that random chaos I
try to post some entertaining videos
when I have them so yeah you can go see
the full video and you can see all this
stuff I did and basically I'm just gonna
go through these techniques walk through
the video the first part of this this
first chunk of video here I actually did
and a different program I was using open
shot video editor and there's some cool
things about open shot but well just to
be perfectly honest with you overall it
sucks it there's a few things it does
it's actually made for video production
unlike blender so there's a few things
it does that is nice like it's a little
easier to transition your tracks and
you're just doing some simple stuff it's
a little better and also it seems to
handle varying frame rates and videos
better so I did actually have to use
this to translate the frame rates of the
different videos because I wanted to do
everything here in blender 60fps but if
you bring in a 30 fps in a 60 FPS video
in blender it doesn't know what to do
and you're just gonna get weird stuff so
just be aware that that's the thing all
your video that you bring into blender
basically needs to be the same frame
rate or you're gonna have odd stuff
happening your audios not gonna line up
with it you might be able to work around
a little bit but there's only so much
you can really do so I did use hope and
shot to render some of my 30 FPS stuff
to 60 that way I could get it that way
so starting right off I have this little
the starting point and this came for OBS
and I had I made some P and G's of some
words and if you watch the video you'll
see it kind of times with the speaking
this is where I get pinned at a car so I
just had those words pop up and it's a
these words actually made him as 1080
images things twenty by ten eighty
images with just a transparent
background and over layered them on top
and just drag them on there and change
the length of them by grabbing in to get
it all lined up and if you grab an end
you can hold ctrl to make it snap all
right so let's continue on go forward
here I'm trying to find them a shot my
partner I do this thing and right here I
do a scratch track I actually did this
an open shot that's why you don't see
any effects here and and then after that
I could this is as far as I could get
before open shot bugged out from just
adding a few effects so I had to come
into blender that's why I came under an
open shot so you're probably wondering
how did you end up in this position yeah
I couldn't get past this this part it's
like open shot was just crashing so I
exported it and started doing the rest
of the work in blender and this is where
I did a little intro some ukulele sound
and I put some keyframes and in there to
fade the sound out at the end you can
see the volume so there are some
keyframes and this little dope sheet
over here I brought over just so I could
see what was going on and I have a few
things going on here this is deep trance
gaming channel presents I put a
transform on it to change the size of it
so that it fit up there in the corner
it's just an image and I ended up
putting these cuts down here I don't
remember why well this one was just - it
was a clip of let's just sound so it's
just a dark screen this transparent
turns into pure black when you render
and this image which says death by taco
I think I have it fade in yeah with the
opacity right there so I put a keyframe
on that if you watch my previous video
on blender video editing I talk more
about keyframes in order to do those but
basically you just press I hover over
and press I and it translates from the
last keyframe and then here I have some
more keyframes I had it scale-up and
then fade out so I had this flying at
you but fading out effect that you see
sometimes so scale up and then fade how
like it was so it's like it's flying
through the screen basically it's the
attention of that effect and then it
goes on there's not a whole lot here we
basically fight a guy takes us a million
shots to kill him eventually we get him
I blow up the car this is how the car
ends up in the middle of the field I
blow up the car cuz like we came through
smokes we couldn't kill him and the car
starts rolling after it blows up and
rolls to the middle of the field
we finally get him somewhere here right
about here I think next shot maybe the
shot boom finally get him and I decide
okay I'm gonna run over and get his gear
it was at this point that streamer choco
taco and his partner stumble across us
and see oh hey look there's a guy had a
burning car over there let's start let's
kill him I started popping shots at me
and I was like oh no that's where the
video started and I cut it so that's why
I made it small so to do this little
pitcher and pitcher thing well let's
first I brought chocolates with you it
and it's all right here I cut it up some
but I put mine over top of it and
transform on it and use that transform
to do scaling and positioning there's a
lot of keyframes here to get it to do
that but yeah as you can see it's
scaling and going down here till I get
it there eventually in that way I reveal
his video and this is his audio I cut
our audio here because he heard of the
beginning the same thing you get to hear
his play and it's it's pretty hilarious
and let's see what do we got here okay
so then I scale the video back up I
gotta click on it okay so she was the
properties or wherever you click scale
my video back up basically what happened
here was pretty hilarious so they were
about to kill me they had me pinned at
this car they were shooting at me and
someone else had shot Chako and so I
started coming back to my video to show
that I was healing and I was like I'm
healing up then I'm gonna run kind of
thing
and what happened here was my partner
killed the guy that was shooting at
choco taco effectively unpinning him so
that they could continue their pressure
on us and of a second which is a bizarre
turn of events that was totally
unprecedented
you never know that oh I should have
left that guy to live because he was
actually helping us it's hard to tell we
thought maybe he was the guy she knows
Todd choco taco calls me some names here
he said at one point he says but the guy
running that behind the car he said
don't worry about that guy he's a little
weenie just cracked me up and they said
oh I think his partner killed a guy that
was shooting at us doesn't know that was
tombow okay so we get back to this
compound they get all rezzed up and then
I scaled down again and they they had
shot both of us at the same time choco
taco and Krupa do both double head shots
synchronized and my partner and I both
die which is pretty hilarious so that
was it and I did all those edits with
blender here I kind of walked through so
yeah there was this whole layer of my
video it was
just translating it to reveal his video
behind I had to do some tricky stuff
with the volumes to try to get it tough
to be good it was really hard to do to
get it sound right I did I noticed when
I had overlapping audio sometimes it was
confusing so I ended I'm just fully
cutting it in some spots on Jacques part
or on our part and it took a while to
get it to feel right and what is this
here oh yeah
this was Jacques video I did a cut here
this actually the same video but I
wanted to put a transform on just a
small part of it because I wanted to
zoom in there or it showed unknown shot
whoever and that was my partner Kelly I
don't know if that's kind of hard to see
in the video but yeah I put this thing
this whole thing together using blender
at the end just have a little outro and
instead of doing and how awful fade at
the end it's like you can do a fade-out
or you can also just add a color shift a
color oh god I'm gonna where it said
that somewhere but you can also add a
color have it at zero opacity so doesn't
show and then you can have it become
more and more invisible to give the
effect of a fade-out and you can do that
with any color you can change the color
of it so you can fade to whatever color
you want that way if you don't want to
just fade to black
that's another way of doing fades and
then I just have some banter and some
square more random con chaos and that's
the end and let's look at the properties
real quick I have it on I don't know how
the FPS ended like ended up is this okay
custom 60.1 so I had to have everything
as 60 frames per second a lot of these
videos like said tried to come in as 30
it was really awkward wouldn't line up
the sound so I basically used OBS to
render them at 60 and get everything 60
to bring into here so you can't do
everything with blender it doesn't
handle everything alright let's see what
other settings so hundred percent
resolution 1080
let's see I changed the folder it went
to and in this little output tab and I
also changed it to let's see what else
to end up clicking here ffmpeg
and I put a a see this defaults to no
audio so you get no sound if you do that
so that's the other thing I had to
change and I output quality I set it up
to lossless which is supposed to help
perceptually lost those losses but yeah
and my final render and went up that as
high as I could maybe even constant
would have been better but it seemed to
be okay so that's it and that's how it
put together a full full video with
blender and that's just a sample
hopefully this helps some of you out
there or stuck trying to figure out what
to do next yeah it takes some some
careful analyzing of getting these
keyframes right and retrospect one of
the okay one of the one of the flaws
here with blender is when you play it
back your audio doesn't stay in sync
with the video and that's kind of
annoying so it's often hard to see how
long things are it can kind of go off
the timing up here but in retrospect on
the real video these only flash on the
screen for a split split second you
can't even read them unless you pause so
I should have drugged these out and it
would have been easy to read them so I
kind of messed that up hindsight 20/20 I
didn't want to go back and rear ender
the whole thing because it took forever
to render but there you go
so thanks for watching the video
hopefully this helps out if you're stuck
on editing and trying to figure out what
you can do what you can't do and if
you're running some of those framerate
pitfalls a way around that to just use
open shot is the solution I came up with
to get them to whatever framerate you
want from there and that's gonna do it I
hope you have a good day and keep on
keepin on peace out